نعود مره اخرى لمتابعه ما يجري الان في
فرنسا من احتجاجات كبيره ضد قانون التقاعد
من باريس سانضم او تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه زين عدي زينه مرحبا بك زينه ما
الذي يجري الان في باريس
منذ حوالي اكثر من ساعه من اكثر من نصف
ساعه كما ترون التظاهره الى الان اجواء
طبيعيه لكن في مدن اخرى كريم ونانس هناك
عنف بين المتظاهرين وبين الشرطه الى الان
التظاهره ستنطلق من هذه الساحه في اتجاه
ساحه الاوبرا وقد تنتهي عند الساعه
السابعه مساء بالنسبه لليوم هو يوم الخميس
الاسود كما اطلق عليه النقابات اليوم
متوقع بان تكون التظاهرات عنيفه الى الان
بحسب النقابات هناك 240 240 نقطه 240 نقطه
بالنسبه للتظاهرات نحن نعلم بان بان اليوم
سيكون حاسما لان فرنسا تنتظر هذا اليوم
لانه اليوم الاول بعد ان اقر للتجمع
التظاهرات بعد خروج
ان اقر هذا القانون قانون رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما المتظاهرون اليوم غاضبون من
خطاب ماكرون في الامس اعتبروا بان مكرون
لم لم يسمع صوتهم ولن يغير شيئا
خطابه في الامس الان التظاهرات لا تكتفي
فقط هنا في هذه الساحه هناك تجمعات عديده
في مناطق اخرى من هنا في العاصمه
المتظاهرون حاولوا ان يقتحموا مطار شاردو
غولا في صباح اليوم ودخلوا عليه وكان هناك
صعوبات للمسافرين في الدخول الى المطار
ايضا في محطه قطار غارد اليوم هنا في
باريس دخل اليها المتظاهرون ومنعوا
القطارات من الحركه والتنقل مظاهر
الاحتجاج واسعه والغضبه
اكثر صوره من خلفك
الاعداد كبيره كما ترون هي اليوم من
المتوقع ان تكون اكبر من السابق الاعداد
ان تكون اكبر من السابق متوقع ان يكون في
باريس وحدها اربعين الف الى 60 الف من
متظاهر بينما في كافه انحاء فرنسا من
المتوقع ان ترسل الاعداد الى 800 الف هذه
هي الاعداد المتوقعه ايضا من قبل السلطات
الفرنسيه بالنسبه لاحدى مراكز الشرطه في
في مدينه لوغيون تعرضت لدخول المحتجين
واذان رئيس
ادانا وزير الداخليه هذا العنف الذي قام
به المتظاهرون والاعتداء على مركز الشرطه
في لوريوم الى الان واضح بان التظاهرات
ستكون عنيفه
ولكن النقابات حاولت ان لكن النقابات
حاولت ان تطلب من المتظاهرين ان يتجنبوا
العنف وان تكون هناك تظاهرات سلميه لكنهم
لا نعتقد بانهم يستطيعون السيطره على
الارض بشكل كامل وهناك تظاهرات عشوائيه
وعفويه غالبا لا تكون مرتبطه بالنقابات
بشكل مباشر
شكرا جزيلا لك زينا عدي مراسله العربيه من
باريس